this is a fascinating case I think
reading from the guardian a jury on
Thursday found a delivery driver not
guilty in the shooting of a YouTube
prankster who followed him around a maul
food court earlier this year Allan kie
uh 31 was acquitted of aggravated
malicious wounding in the shooting of
Tanner cook 21 who runs the classified
goons YouTube channel the jury was split
on two lesser firearm counts and decided
to convict him on one and acquit him on
the other the shooting on April 2nd uh
at the food court in dullas town center
about 45 minutes west of the Na's
Capital set off Panic as Shoppers fled
what they feared to be a mass shooting
collie pleaded not guilty and said he
was acting in self-defense the verdict
came on Thursday after about 5 hours of
deliberation three hours in the jury
sent out a note saying it was divided in
terms of whether the defendant acted in
self-defense the Lowden County Circuit
uh Court Judge Matthew snow called the
jury back into the courtroom at
approximately 3:30 p.m. and urged them
to continue
deliberations and um and then they uh
came down with the verdict at the end of
that day uh klie who's been in custody
since his April arrest will remain
incarcerated uh Adam pullyard his
defense attorney said during Thursday's
closing arguments as client felt menaced
by the s 6 fo 5 in cook during the
confrontation which was designed to
provoke a reaction and to draw viewers
to Cook's YouTube channel okay so kie
was acquitted of the uh serious the more
serious charge still convicted of the
Lesser charge and that part makes no
sense because if you buy his
self-defense claim if you buy that claim
so you're you're acquitting him of the
uh of the malicious wounding
charge then it makes no logical sense to
convict him of the Firearms charge if
he's justified in using self-defense
then it it's like basically you're
saying he's justified in shooting the
guy but not justified in discharging the
firearm which that that logically it
makes no sense but jurries do this all
the time now where they kind of split
the baby in a way that makes no logical
sense at all so that at the end of it
you're trying to figure out what their
theory of the case even is and it's it
doesn't there isn't
one um and his lawyers will you know of
course try to appeal the conviction on
the Lesser account I think
ultimately you know they're going to win
that argument just just because it
doesn't the verdict doesn't make sense I
either he was either his self-defense
claim was legitimate or not and if it's
not a legitimate claim that he should
have been convicted of the of the
malicious wounding charge he wasn't
which means that jury found it uh found
it legitimate and so there should be no
conviction of
anything
um so the question is should he have
been acquitted um of the of the more
serious charge or of all the charges I
believe absolutely yes he should have he
should have been he should be acquitted
of everything and he should walk free he
should be walking free right now he
shouldn't be in jail at all um and I've
been arguing about this on on Twitter
and and which is always a productive
thing to do and lots of people are uh
mad at me and they they disagree um even
people who profess to be big supporters
of the Second Amendment I've heard a lot
there's been a lot of that you know I'm
a big Second Amendment person but you're
way off on this this person was totally
wrong well let's watch the video um that
this YouTube prankster quote unquote
took where you know we can see the whole
thing and this is what the prank quote
unquote consisted of and I'm going to
show you everything leading up to when
the shot was fired cuz that's the
important part the actual shot itself if
I play that then the vi the violence and
they'll take down the video and
everything so you can go and find the
actual shot itself if you want to find
it but um here you can see what led up
to him ultimately um pulling out his gun
and firing let's watch
that what quit thinking about my twink
what's
that quit thinking about my
twinkle quit thinking about my twink
stop thinking about my
stop and then right there he's about to
pull the trigger so that's the prank uh
the hilarious prank the prank is that
this large massive guy we just heard 6'
5 in and um the other guy quite a bit I
don't know how tall the other guy is but
quite a bit smaller than that so it's
massive guy comes up starts weirdly and
ominously harassing a random door Dash
driver is just trying to pick up some
food and uh and deliver it to a customer
door Dash I don't know what service he's
driving for but he's he's delivering
food um and this guy comes up and he's
got his phone out and he's like putting
it's it's it's repeating this weird
phrase and he's putting it in um in
colie's face and he keeps pursuing him
getting very very close to him you know
and colie's backing away and he says
stop three
times says stop three times he's trying
he's trying to get away he's trying to
leave it's not like he he's trying to
leave the situation he's being
pursued and after the third warning he
takes out the gun and he shoots
him and some people have taken issue
with it because when he took out the gun
you know he took out the gun and he did
after taking out the gun he just fired
it immediately he didn't take out the
gun and say I'm warning you he didn't
warn a fourth time after taking out the
gun he just
shot and I'm and I'm I think it's
totally justified I have no problem with
that he had every right to assume that
cook meant him harm because he had no
context okay he didn't know that cook
was some stupid dumb o YouTuber who was
doing this as a
prank okay he's not like put yourself in
that position you you this happens
you're not immediately oh you're you're
not thinking oh this is a YouTube
prank you're not thinking that I mean
you you're you're thinking why is this
massive guy coming after me what is he
doing he's got this blank expression on
his face and he's just got like you you
think obviously you're going to assume
that he's crazy he's like some psycho
and uh and he means you harm if I was in
that exact situation I would immediately
assume that he meant me harm that's what
I would
assume and uh that would be a a safe
assumption it's a fair assumption and
it's an assumption that I believe we
have every right to
make and the benefit of the doubt in
that scenario has to go entirely to kie
not to the guy who initiated the
confrontation to begin
with so for me not Not only would I say
that colie was justified in shooting him
but to me it's like clear as day there's
not even anything I know I said it's a
fascinating case um it's actually not
even that interesting to me I saw that
video I like oh of course you yeah shoot
him go
ahead like don't don't go up to someone
harassing them like that in in a in in
this ominous way they tell you to stop
and you keep going after him don't do
that you don't want to get get shot just
don't do that it's very easy it's very
easy to not get shot in that situation
just don't do
that and calling it a prank doesn't all
of a sudden make it
okay could colie what what if kie could
klie try that could he shoot him and say
no dude no bro I'm just it's just a
prank shoot him in the stomach which is
what he did and then what if he had just
stood over him and said just a prank bro
don't worry about it just a prank look
you're on camera see you're on YouTube
don't worry it's just a prank
uh no calling it a prank doesn't
suddenly make everything okay uh but
this is what we find these these these
uh clout chasers on YouTube or Tik Tok
or whatever you know of course the
infamous example of the guy on Tik Tok
who does home invasion he walks into
people's homes as part of a prank for
most homeowners window replacement isn't
something they've done before and for
many it's not something they really want
to do but rather something they have to
do if you've put off replacing windows
in your home because it's too expensive
I have great news for you you can get
you can now get a free inhome window
consultation and free price quote from
Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature service is
committed to to giving you the best
customer service and experience possible
through the perfect combination of the
best people in the industry a superior
process and an exclusive product right
now Renewal by Anderson is offering a
free inhome or virtual consultation on
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for zero dollars down zero
payments and zero interest for a year
all you have to do is textt Walsh to 200
300 for your free consultation to save
$375 off every window and $750 off every
door these savings won't last long so be
sure to check it out by texting Walsh to
2300 that's Walsh to 200030 texting
privacy policy in terms of conditions
posted at text plan. us texting uh
enrolls for recurring automated text
marketing messages message and data
rates apply reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointment
now.com for full offer
details this is not a prank this is this
home invasion harassment these are
crimes you're
committing and I think people have every
right to uh to respond and I also think
look look I admit that um when I look at
a case like
this I am not an entirely unbiased
Observer I suppose I am very much
biased in the favor of in favor of the
person who feels that they're being
threatened and has to defend themselves
I'm going to be biased in their favor um
now it's one thing look if if that had
happened and
then the guy the YouTuber says Ah it's
just a prank and he kind of like starts
walking away and then kie is just mad he
gets pissed off that he was harassed and
he walks up to the guy and shoots him
okay well now it's murder so that's a
totally different scenario we're not
talking about that you you that I'm
saying that if you are a carry a gun
that you should have license to just
kill whoever you want if you're pissed
off you can just kill someone obviously
not but what I'm saying is that in the
moment in that moment where someone is
confused they don't know what you're
doing they feel
threatened uh I'm going to
give a lot of leeway personally I think
we should be giving a lot of leeway to
the person who is feeling threatened and
who also is not the one who initiated
the
confrontation
I and I also think that on a societal
level because I know there's always this
worry about oh it's going to become the
wild west and never mind that in the
wild west actually often times the gun
laws were quite harsh and there were you
know many towns you go into you're not
even allowed to bring your firearm in uh
but you know it's going to be the wild
west people are just shooting all over
the place that's the concern I I don't
think that is the concern I don't think
that's going to
happen
um I think the concern is more what we
the situation we currently have in
society where you've got these uh these
Thugs and these
punks who who have no compunction they
have no fear they'll just go up they'll
harass you they'll assault you they'll
do whatever and with no fear at
all no fear of the legal consequences
and especially no fear of the physical
consequences in the
moment I think it is good and healthy in
a
society for people to fear for their
lives before deciding to victimize or
harass someone like I think it's a
healthy it's a sign of a healthy
Society if you're about to harass
someone randomly for clicks and then you
stop and say to
yourself I don't know if I want to do
that I might die I might die if I do
that that's a healthy
Society where you have to take those
kinds of things into
consideration and then and then if
you're not insane you'll probably say to
yourself yeah you know it's not worth it
it's not worth it I think I'll just you
know what I'll just I'll just be a
normal person instead and I'll leave
this person alone and I'll let them make
their delivery and I'll go about my day
and that'll be
it okay A a healthy Society to me is one
where people are incentivized to make
healthy choices and to be just normal
well adjusted contributing members of
society if you are incentivized in that
direction and there are strong
disincentives
to be a burden to be a leech to be just
a punk a thug you know that to me is
healthy um which is
why I think we should uh be very very
generous uh to people like collie in
that situation which the which the jury
almost was you know if not for the uh
ridiculous splitting the baby bit there
at the end hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to daily wi.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there